don't work
tell starts moving [ __ ] yeah
third floor press the button
well my fingers are no
not much left to clean up probably
hear that tonight is today
all right guys this one
i like
go
remember that tape from all foods that's
the joomla did royce
no no no no no it wouldn't be that
stupid to show up here
you the one
looking for best isis guess i gotta
spell it out
you the one took out royce
yeah what anyone actually boo-hoo when
he went
look at this a chance at a nick in the
barrel
get the [ __ ] out now that's the all
foods pawn i'm not blind
who do you want watch out for that this
isis mean anything to you you work with
her
no just gotta talk heard she's here
gotta talk sure
i'll take you
too easy this is going worry later find
nancy
first
to be honest should be thanking you for
what
getting royce out of the way was about
time
worked out pretty well for me too no
problem
anytime
wouldn't mind playing this venue
i already said i music media yeah you
said
how in the [ __ ] you search her tundar
that she still managed to call for help
[ __ ]
that's nets did a number on it huh
i didn't call anyone i don't even know
him but we do
and we won't have history repainting
itself
dammit
[Music]
oh [ __ ] thanks let's get her out of here
so who are you v
carry uridine sent me carrie
[ __ ] i do not get this uh uh must have
spent too much time with paranoid patty
in there
it's about samurai talk later okay
right let's delta follow me i'll get us
out of here
elevator over there let's go
for you
hmm
cars outside
you all right i've had better days
that gunket was sure i was a goddamn spy
come on [ __ ] just hope the car is still
where i parked it
why did you come here really wanted to
do a story on the music at the tote
intense
no wonder patricia didn't buy your story
oh for [ __ ] sake could have been worse
this way you got a souvenir [ __ ]
souvenirs
i'm headed straight back to the editing
room wanna talk
gotta come with me conquer like this
hope it gets us there
one piece
all right so what's carrie want wants to
bring back samurai
one gig one night there is no samurai
without silver hands
gonna be a gig in silver hand's honor
let's get into carry all of a sudden
i thought he got over this ages ago well
guess it doesn't really matter
what's in it for me
believe i just saved your ass and your
precious story
mean to ask how do you know royce biz
some time ago fascinating son of a [ __ ]
isn't he
is
[Music]
we're here hop out all right so the
concert
tell carry out put it together be in
touch
okay thanks
went pretty damn well now call carrie
hey so how'd it go talk to nance
yep she agreed even said she'd organize
the gig
still a control frame your only worry is
getting stuck in traffic
managed to contact henry or danny just
henry so far dragged him out of rehab
great story actually henry didn't know
then he's been in night city all this
time on his way over to see her now
gonna be a surprise we're all gonna meet
over at dennis
what me too why can't play with us
aren't you
i gotta meet the others send you the
address
where's
so
see those what happened here
she must have been renovating henry must
have borrowed the truck
gonk always was good at improvising
maybe they're home try the intercom
right then guess we keep looking
what are you doing here v
this is really yours you're back up we
got a problem case you forgot why the
hell you came here in the first place
carrie sent me it's about the concert
what concert why isn't he here talking
to me
we're bringing back samurai one night
only
that's what he wants to get the crew
together for sweet
but no [ __ ] way not about to play
with this
[ __ ] stain danny no no way
either him or me choose
then he digs in her heels we're done
how's it going like [ __ ] man
danny wants me out of the gig and we
already agreed on everything
what kerry's paying you that's what this
is about
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] great so you get
him away from me and get the [ __ ] off my
lawn
don't make me choose
what are we doing maybe if someone would
tell me what happened
are you blind [ __ ] filled my pool with
cement
maybe he had a good reason really
a reason
you out of your [ __ ] line with the
pool you knew
carrie wanted to get danny to play with
us just wanted to clear the air
[ __ ]
pretty sure it's your call [ __ ] really
pisses me off then he's on a control
kick
setting conditions on the other hand
henry's got scott for brains
can't trust him thanks
real helpful
about to run completely out of patience
we got to go without one or the other ah
yeah not a problem should be able to
borrow someone else
one gig won't be the same though
it won't ever be the same kerry
ugh if we gotta choose let's play with
danny
[ __ ] karen seriously she's the one
making a big deal out of this not me
listen i'll get you you know what carrie
[ __ ] you
good thing silverhand isn't here to see
this
you done get out
all right what about nancy we made
contact
she's gonna set it all up and let us
know
see at the show [ __ ]
now i gotta find someone to clean this
up
okay about all we can do for now except
wait